MGM is still looking for a leading man
for the new Stargate franchise and have
they found him welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so I told you news a couple of months
ago now that Liam Hemsworth was in
conversations with Amazon and MGM to
become the leading man for the new
Stargate franchise Amazon would really
like all of the pieces of their jigsaw
puzzle to be in place when they finally
announced the new Stargate franchise and
one of those pieces is a leading man to
take the show forwards a woman could be
a woman in this case it's a man now
that's kind of like how Amazon like to
do things they've done it with other
projects if you look at Warhammer and
other things like that they tend to
always have the production team in place
at least one or two of the actors the
main actor in particular and then they
let it out and blooded out public to the
world now they did speak to Liam
Hemsworth Liam Hemsworth was apparently
interested in there were some very
preliminary negotiations
Hemsworth ended up signing on to the
fourth season of The Witcher that's
gonna go well apparently there was lots
of reasons why that happened one being
that he started sort of like asking for
producer roles and things which is just
stupid
um but also because there was no
showrunner in place and there still
isn't now we're still having
negotiations in the Penguin and Parker
and a simple problem is that they
probably are going to do a movie first
there isn't actually an executive in
charge of MGM of movies even though that
role is being done by Amazon so they are
still moving forward to things it was
causing delays delays that Lee Hemsworth
didn't want to wait for people at MGM
and Amazon have been looking for someone
else and they might have found him the
actor's name Miles Teller by the way
guys don't forget to like And subscribe
Sidetrack is the place to go for all of
your sci-fi news we also have a Discord
server a merchandise store and nine
Chevrons the website where we put all of
the stories from garden Stargate first
all of the links are in the description
now Amazon are looking for a very
specific type of actor they need
somebody that will go oh I know him but
that is not so popular and so big that
basically he would be too expensive they
need somebody as well that can carry a
movie but also carry a TV series they
think they found that man in Miles
Teller now that is almost certainly a
name you won't know but you do know him
he is Goose's son from Top Gun Maverick
he was also in that really terrible
Fantastic Four movie a few years ago he
did play Mr Fantastic and he was very
forgettable at it and actually he was Mr
kind of mediocre
the whole movie was
but he is a very very accomplished actor
and this is the man that apparently MGM
are currently looking at so if you are a
regular site tracker you'll know that I
have several sources that I talk to in
and around MGM and Amazon two of those
sources have let me know actually that
Miles teller's agent was at MGM in the
last few weeks Miles Teller is currently
signed on to the creative artists agency
CAA a very long-standing agency in
Hollywood still based in LA
Tracy Brennan is Miles teller's agent
and according to my sources she has had
meetings we don't know if they're face
to face or over like teams or something
we don't know for certain
um with Executives from MGM since the
new year so that's basically within the
last week
my sources are for me this was a very
early conversation a kind of a would he
be interested if he did what sort of
thing would he like to do that kind of
conversation we're not anywhere near
negotiations we're not anywhere near an
offer I should also say that a lot of
The Whispers I'm hearing at the moment
are about a movie not a TV series at the
moment but when Stargate returns it will
be a movie first now that isn't definite
yet but again I'm hearing that there is
apparently a script now unfortunately to
protect my sources I can't say any more
than that but the script is for a movie
now that doesn't actually really mean
anything at this point
a lot of the time they will write a
script for a movie and it'll get turned
into a two-parter opener for a series or
vice versa things like this happen all
the time just because a script has been
written for a movie doesn't mean that's
what's going to happen but it is
interesting that this is floating around
and it is interesting that they're
talking to an actor like Miles Teller an
actor that has done several movies in
the past an actor that I believe could
carry a movie franchise but also that
has done television he was a very
popular character in Top Gun Maverick
Goose's son
there for Christ's sake I troubles
and I genuinely think he actually would
be perfect for franchise like Stargate
particularly if he was willing to invest
the time now that is a big sticking
point is he going to be interested in
investing the time into a franchise that
this would require this could take up
the next 10 years of his life he could
be doing movies and a streaming series
or would he just say I'll sign up for
the movie but nothing else thank you
very much obviously now we're just
speculating we have no bloody clue but
what I'm trying to say is
any actor that takes on this role is
going to be investing a significant
portion of their lives to the Stargate
franchise he or she and most definitely
going to have to be really invested in
that project if they're going to sign on
the dotted line so what does marstellar
got in the works at the moment because
when we look at his IMDb and see maybe
How likely this is obviously if he's got
projects through till 2027 it's not
likely well he doesn't
he has two movies currently in
production The Gorge and the forge they
rhyme both these movies are not big
budgets Blockbusters they are relatively
small Productions and will probably only
take up three or four months each so
nothing major there he's doing a voice
in a movie in 2024 The Arc and the
aardvark and he has got something in
early development for 2024 as well The
Life and Times of the stopwatch gang but
who knows if that'll even go into
production
so he's not particularly busy if he was
tapped up for this it's something he
could potentially film by the end of the
year which if they go for a movie that's
the soonest they're going to start
filming
and he is an actor of the right sort of
caliber I.E big enough that you know who
he is but not so big that he would be
too expensive
or unwilling to do the TV element of the
project
he's also got the bonus of actually
coming off a massive success of topic on
Maverick so people are interested in
Miles Teller again people know the face
and people will perk up and take notice
if he is announced as lead in the
Stargate franchise so really for Amazon
and MGM he would tick all the boxes I'm
just going to throw in here a very very
quick update as well about what's going
on at Stargate at the moment I did tell
you in previous videos that just before
the new year there were meetings between
Michael Wright the head of scripted
television at MGM and
um Mark Fergus from penguin and Parker
those meetings didn't go particularly
well I have been reassured by several
sources and that's normal conversations
and normal negotiations and that the
relationship between penguin and park
and Amazon is very strong that they will
figure out mostly it's about budget they
will figure out those numbers and
they're very confident that this will
still continue to move forwards there
are new meetings this week um not
between Mark Fergus and Executives from
MGM so not Michael Wright Etc but there
are meetings between their teams this
week and those conversations are still
going on it's basically I imagine again
I'm speculating here but they've sort of
the bosses have told them what the
problems are and they're going to try to
maybe come up with some sort of counter
proposal
let's see what happens apparently
towards the end of this week or early
next week there are supposed to be
meetings between Mark Fergus and Michael
Wright again and hopefully with Jennifer
sulky from Amazon
but let's see how that develops in the
coming weeks
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit the Bell notification
it really helps us out and if you really
want to support the channel consider
hitting the join Button as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]